we have a lot of young women these days
with a lot of artificially lowered
voices because they can't get their
voices back once they've been on
testosterone a lot of women
have had double mastectomies
and will never have their natural
breasts back
and people sort of brush that off and
say well they can just get synthetic
ones and it's like how are we here
how on earth are we here um and it's
there are plenty of boys and young men
who are going through this as well it's
just much more prevalent in young women
because it's young women who are being
pressured into this more than boys and
that's not to say i lack sympathy for
the boys who are going through this of
course i have tremendous sympathy for
boys
you know how how graphic do you can can
we be here no be graphic people should
know what's going on like this is awful
[Music]
welcome to episode 152 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson i had kara danske on
cara is a lawyer public speaker and
writer and a self-described feminist
fighting for the sex-based rights of
women and girls publicly speaking out
about the gender identity industry don't
run away yet i never associated myself
with feminism i didn't really see a need
for it i actually argued against kind of
the woke feminism that was starting to
present itself in my high school and
definitely in my university however we
have gone so far backwards in regards to
women's rights that we spoke about
feminism legal precedents that affect
women in america
trans athletes the biden administration
the dana rivers case and more i hope you
enjoy this episode it's one that
everyone with a kid or anyone thinking
of having kids or anyone who has family
in high schools or elementary schools
should watch
or if you want to know more about what's
actually happening to mostly little
girls because of woke politics it's
gruesome and it needs to be spoken about
this trans discussion and debate isn't
about inclusion anymore we had inclusion
already toronto did anyway where i grew
up what i'm concerned about is having
kids brainwashed and confused in
elementary school to the point where
they want to be put on hormones and
drugs and do surgery under the age of 18
that causes irreversible damage all done
under the context of being nice and
inclusive
what's going on in the public schools
and in america regarding gender
reassignment isn't nice it's destroying
people's lives
so we talk about that before we get into
that this episode was brought to you by
nordvpn have you guys been watching the
boys the tv show if not
and you don't mind serious blood and
gore the actors do an amazing job
i used to get all my good tv shows in
canada through nordvpn
now i'm in land of the free ish that
could go either way and i mostly use
nordvpn to protect myself online nordvpn
has state of the art encryption that
keeps you safe from hackers malware and
other sneaky threats lurking all over
the internet
nordvpn never buffers or crashes with
over 5300 servers around the world which
translates into connection speeds of up
to
6730 megabits per second
that's insane
take advantage of their exclusive
limited time offer today and see what
full online protection really feels like
grab your nordvpn deal today over at
nordvpn.com
tmpp or use code tmpp for 61 off their
premium plan and their free anti-malware
feature all with nordvpn's 30-day
money-back guarantee
enjoy this episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me
so i
spotted you on twitter i think somebody
tagged me in a tweet you had sent out
and said we should chat
and so i went ahead and
did some research on you and read your
book
um
and invited you on and canceled a whole
bunch of times but now here we are
so i'm really glad you can be here
before we get started can you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
sure thanks so much um so i'm a lawyer i
got my law degree and i spent about 20
years working
in what i would refer to as the
progressive criminal justice reform
movement in the u.s
that came to a halt
uh toward the late
uh 20 15 16 17 18 19 i started getting
involved in women's liberation front and
now i'm the president of the u.s chapter
of women's declaration international in
the meantime i wrote a book called the
abolition of sex how the transgender
agenda harms women and girls and now
because of the work that i've been doing
on you know rattle radical feminist uh
critiques of so-called gender identity
it is no longer possible for me to get
work in the criminal justice reform
community which is fine i'm very happy
to be doing what i'm doing
okay that's a lot to take in so
you said it's no longer possible for you
to get work why why is that
so
between 2015 and 2018 i was doing
independent consulting work on a broad
range of topics including drug policy
reform immigration policy uh mass
incarceration police militarization
and things like that and i was doing
this project that was a really
interesting project involving
immigration advocacy
and federal public defenders at the u.s
mexico border
and the person that i had my contract
with
informed me that because i'm a known
turf i'm toxic to the project and so she
had to cancel my contract she did so uh
reluctantly
she really liked working with me and she
wanted to keep me on but other people
involved told her that i was toxic to
the project and that i had to go
and i understood exactly why that was
because of how all of this is playing
out throughout our society and then
later i got a job in 2018 at a dc city
agency
and in early 2019
i appeared on a panel at the heritage
foundation called the inequality of the
equality act concerns from the left
and that made a lot of people really
angry and they complained to my boss
and over the course of 2018 2019 it just
became untenable it became impossible
for me to speak out about this topic
during non-work hours i never allowed my
work with women's liberation front or
women's declaration international to
interfere with my job but nonetheless
people were so angry at things that i
was saying during my non-work hours on
sex and gender that they basically just
kept harassing my boss and she kept
having to spend a lot of time dealing
with it and i had to spend a lot of time
dealing with it and eventually i just
quit my job
and that was the end of 2019 and so i've
just been talking a lot about sex and
gender ever since
okay can you describe what a turf is
so
the acronym turf stands for
trans-exclusionary radical feminist oh
yes okay i have heard that yes
so
these are women who
the term was invented by people who were
very angry that women were standing up
for ourselves and demanding to be
known as a sex class women and girls
exist as a coherent category of people
distinct from men and boys and a lot of
people really don't like that
turf okay
okay
so what what does women's liberation
front do
women's liberation front does a number
of things including fighting for the
abolition of gender it's currently got a
lawsuit before federal district court in
the in federal court in california
complaining about a california law that
mandates the incarceration of men and
boys or men rather in the women's prison
and there are under california law as
far as i know a couple of hundred men
being housed in the women's prison and
wolf currently has a lawsuit pending
challenging that in federal court
arguing that the policy allowing men and
women's prisons violates the first
amendment the eighth amendment and
various other constitutional provisions
i should say i'm not directly involved
in that lawsuit nor do i currently serve
on the board of women's liberation front
although i am a member
wow so it sounds like you lead us
somewhat stressful life
you know it was stressful for a period
of time but it just feels so important
to be able to have honest conversations
about sex and gender that i'm i'm sort
of used to it by now
okay well that's good
so
you claim in your book uh that the term
transgender was invented to serve a
political purpose
can you walk me through uh that argument
so my understanding is that in the 1960s
and 70s
continuing into the 80s there was a
growing movement within the academy
coming out of post-modernism right so
post-modernism is sort of this idea that
material reality doesn't exist
and so coming out of post-modernism
came queer theory which was the idea
that the material reality of biological
sex doesn't exist however
if a bunch of academics had tried to
persuade ordinary average everyday
americans across the political spectrum
that the material reality of biological
sex doesn't exist they wouldn't have
been able to do it because everybody
knows what a man is and what a woman is
and so they they invented the term my
argument is that they invented the term
transgender to make it sound as though
there is a coherent category of people
who are being deprived of civil rights
but that's just not true
okay so um from what i know the the
argument that's more in favor of
transgenderism or lack of a better
description would be that there was a
fairly significant subset of people that
identified as transgender that were
always ignored that had high suicide
rates because they weren't allowed to
express themselves properly
what's your opinion on that argument
there's just no evidence that it's true
i mean there's just literally no
credible evidence that there's that
that's true there's no support for it
whatsoever you know we know from
studying science and evolution that
human beings evolved and that we are
mammals and because we're mammals all of
us every single one of us is either
female or male like every other mammal
on the face of the planet
okay so how did we get to where we are
now because i know i've seen in
elementary schools you know what they're
starting to teach people as early as
kindergarten that gender doesn't exist
and that everyone should be you know
free to express themselves in whatever
they way they want to how did we go from
men and women you know women's actual
women's rights women deserve rights to
where we are now which is
having men on women's swim teams
so
a couple things are going on here one of
which is that at the founding of the
republic
uh
the
uh there's a reason i'm talking about
this the united states constitution did
not address women's suffrage instead
choosing to leave the matter to the
individual states and at the founding of
the republic not a single state allowed
women to vote because they're women
right women were excluded from the vote
on the basis of sex the first state to
allow women to vote was not even a state
at the time it was the wyoming territory
and it enacted a law in the late 18th
century i think maybe late 19th century
that said it was called something like
female
franchisement female enfranchisement and
it said that going forward women would
be allowed to vote but the reason that
that law was necessary is because women
had been excluded from the vote on the
basis of sex
and now all of a sudden we're
being told that sex doesn't exist as a
material category which is very
frustrating
to women including feminists who are
very interested in fighting for the
rights of the category of people called
women
so
what happened in schools one of the
things you touched on is
kids are being taught that they should
be able to express themselves in
whatever ways that they want and i think
that i would completely agree with that
i think it's very important that kids be
able to explore their personalities
their expressions their preferences
regarding hairstyle and clothing and
whatever else and as they get older
sexuality
but that doesn't mean that any kids
ought to be or even can
be encouraged that it's possible to
change their sex
in other words if a boy wants to wear a
pink dress
encouraging him to do that
is is great right we ought to be
encouraging kids to be able to embrace
the expressions that they feel best fits
with their personality but the idea that
that makes him a girl is first of all
untrue second of all extremely dangerous
to his psychological development and
third of all grounded in regressive
stereotypes that say that girls are like
supposed to like pink dresses and boys
are like supposed to like blue pants
right feminists have been fighting
against these stereotypes forever and
now this
ideology is to a great extent grounded
in the stereotypes that we wish could be
abolished
yeah it's confused me a bit
because it seems to
be coming from people who 15 years ago
were feminists
and now it feel like you can tell me if
i'm wrong here but it feels like those
same people have somehow switched over
to oh no now it's transgenderism we're
fighting for rather than women
yeah i mean it is confusing and i would
say that
what feminists were saying 10 years ago
was that kids shouldn't be forced into
sex stereotypes among other things
feminists have been saying a lot of
things for decades but one of them was
that kids shouldn't be forced into sex
stereotypes and i would stand by that
statement then and today but a lot of
people seem to have shifted from kids
shouldn't be forced into sex stereotypes
to if a kid likes a sex stereotype that
makes the kid the opposite sex that's a
very different thing from what feminists
have been saying this whole time
so how
how many people are kind of fighting in
the same way you are because generally
speaking when you hear the term feminist
now
i
generally speaking equate that with
people who are very far left who are
fighting for these um transgender this
transgender movement when i when i hear
feminism that's what i assume people
believe in so
um you identify as a feminist but as a
true feminist and is there a group of
people that are behind you here
you know it's of course completely
understandable that you think that
because the mainstream media would have
you believe it all the sort of
mainstream large
organizations that claim to be feminist
organizations like national association
for women planned parenthood national
center for lesbian rights all of them
are pushing the idea that some men can
be women and they do that by referring
to a co to a category of transgender
women but we're talking about men um are
there people behind me yeah absolutely
um so i'm the president of women's
declaration international u.s chapter we
have over 5 000 signatories to the
declaration on women's sex based rights
which is a global document that seeks to
enshrine women's sex-based rights in law
all over the world we're global
the document has over 31 000 signatures
globally again over 5000 in the states
and as you mentioned women's liberation
front is also fighting for the sex-based
rights of women and girls so we're out
here and and we do this and we talk
about this stuff all the time
one thing that is very frustrating is
that we cannot get a voice in most
mainstream media outlets
they don't even mention us and when they
mention us they disparage us and say
that we're right-wing even though most
of us
almost all of us come from
a left-wing political
value system
um but we're here and i don't know if
you know where your viewers know i have
never watched fox news in my life i was
never a fan of tucker carlson i've ended
up going on tucker carlson i think like
eight or nine times now because he will
platform people like me who will say
things like this
and even though i disagree with tucker
carlson on probably just about
everything i'm grateful for the platform
because it's a way to get the word out
yeah it's pretty crazy things are pretty
crazy right now i always identified uh
more as a liberal too i'm pretty much
like let people do i guess libertarian
just like let people do what they want
to do express themselves how they want
to express themselves like whatever as
long as you leave me alone i'm fine
pretty much
um although now with this
i have a four-year-old girl
and i've been actively concerned about
where to put her because i'll go on
school websites and you can kind of see
on their website what agenda they're
pushing
and it shocks me that there aren't more
women standing up to this like most of
even my female friends because i come
from more of a leftist background most
of my female friends are like oh it's
fine you know what's going on is fine
and some of my you know male friends too
what's going on is fine and and then you
see things like you know if you have one
man competing in a women's high school
sports team
that diminishes every woman on that team
objectively it's like just objectively
and i was like how is this okay
with people who are trying to stand up
for women i i just don't understand how
people can be as brainwashed as they are
right now and it's strange to me that
somebody like you
would have a spot
on
tucker carlson's show
and that
more left-wing
media sources aren't picking up on this
and agreeing with what you're pushing
because i i it just it boggles my mind
yeah so you're right that having a man
participate in a women's swimming team
disadvantages all the women on that team
it also crucially disadvantages
the woman who he replaced on that team
right there's a woman who's not even
competing at all
when there's a man on the team assuming
that the team accepts a certain number
of athletes um so it's important to
understand that this is very well funded
and there's a i i argue in the book that
there's a loosely affiliated
conglomeration of
businesses
law firms
media outlets
um
corporations
and academic institutions that are all
sort of working together to push this
and there's a lot of money behind it one
really great source of information for
this is called the 11th hour blog
and the author of that blog goes into an
astonishing degree of detail regarding
the money that is fueling this
so
it is just not the case which we have
been told that transgender is a coherent
category of people who are just fighting
for their civil rights it's just not
true it is a very top-heavy very heavily
funded uh top-down movement to abolish
sex throughout society and people have
bought it i don't know why people have
bought it i'm as mystified as you are um
but a lot of people haven't and i hear
from people on social media and on email
frequently from the political left
saying how did this happen i'm not going
along with this and so that's really
good uh but again the media won't
platform our voices and so
lefties democrats uh feminists gay
rights activists all over the country
feel very isolated because they think
they're alone they like you have friends
who say this is fine we should just go
along with this and people all over the
country are thinking why is this fine
but they think they're alone and so
they're afraid to say something
so how could this possibly be making
anybody money
so one example is john striker he
is um he founded something called the
arcus foundation he's a very wealthy man
he's a billionaire and he founded
something called the arcus foundation
which hands out grants multi-million
dollar grants to fund this
it
they literally give money to fund this
yes and uh mr striker is also
heir to a medical supply company so if
you started connecting
yeah yeah so you connected that dot
pretty quickly
oh no okay so can you connect that dot
for anybody listening who hasn't
connected that dot what kind of medical
supply chain what
what is he heavily invested in
so the medical supply interest industry
stands to gain a lot of money and earn a
lot of profit by conducting cosmetic
surgeries on confused children and young
people
we can't omit pharma pharma of course
makes a ton of profit from putting a
generation's worth of children and young
people on a lifetime's worth of hormones
that is
terrifying
also completely makes sense
wow okay um what percentage of these
what percentage of trans kids
that are put on
drugs are women versus or little you
know girls versus little boys
yeah it's interesting and it seems to be
changing every day for a while it was
thought that the overwhelming majority
of people who identify as trans are men
uh claiming to be women whether they got
any hormones or surgery or not but we're
seeing an exponential increase in the
number of girls and young women who are
going to gender clinics going on
testosterone getting
mastectomies that are not medically
necessary
abigail schreier has documented all of
this in her book irreversible damage i
don't know the stats for the u.s but i
know that in the uk in a matter of just
a tiny handful of years i think it's
three years the percentage of young
girls and women who went to the nhs
gender clinic shot up 4 000
oh that's awful as if being a teenager
isn't confusing enough i don't know yeah
like people experience anxiety when i
was in grade four
for a multitude of reasons i i cut off
all my hair
which i didn't want to be a little boy i
just cut off my hair and then people
were referring to me as a boy because
you kind of look the same when you're a
little kid
and i was on all the sports teams and i
refused to wear dresses
and i like
i was kind of a nerd
so
i would be very concerned for any kid
kind of in the same position that's a
tomboy like there are lots of little
girls that are tomboys i'm certainly not
one anymore but like i i was back then
and i'd be concerned for
any kid in a school that's ideologically
that has ideologically possessed
teachers
that are more tomboyish because then
it's like oh well do you feel you know
like you're you identify more with other
like little boy or little boys
are you more comfortable being friends
with boys maybe maybe you want to
express yourself that way maybe that's
what you actually truly are
right and having that kind of
conversation with an adult you'd be so
confused as a kid
yeah i mean that's actually already
happening teachers are telling people
kids as young as four and five that if
they
like certain stereotypes then that
actually makes them the opposite sex
i've heard of stories of teachers
making gender closets they literally use
the word closet and when a kid comes to
school dressed in whatever the kids
dressed in
teachers will put kids in the closet and
have them change clothes without their
parents knowing
teachers will
start referring to kids using the kids
chosen name without telling the parents
kids teachers will start referring to
kids using the kids preferred pronouns
without informing the parents this is
happening today
how
how often though i had somebody else on
my podcast who mentioned this closet
thing that's happening is that an
isolated incident or is this something
that's happening
in every state in america
i don't know if well the closet itself i
don't know how prevalent that is but the
phenomenon of teachers telling kids that
they can be the opposite sex that is
rampant that is absolutely rampant all
over the country
that's insane you know and just to your
point about how hard it is to be a
teenager
it's it's really hard to be a teenage
girl right our bodies change in ways
that are just physically uncomfortable
psychologically confusing and all of a
sudden men start treating us differently
right they start looking at us
differently and they start acting
differently towards us and it can be
really hard and it's especially hard for
teenage girls who might be feeling same
sex attracted and it's just devastating
that today if teenage girls are starting
to explore a same-sex attraction they're
being told that they're actually boys
because girls aren't allowed to like
girls it's only boys who are allowed to
like girls which is maybe one of the
most homophobic things one could think
about
that's interesting
that that definitely makes sense that
definitely makes sense um
um
what has the biden administration done
or is trying to do in terms of gender
legislation currently
so on the first day of taking office
president biden signed executive order
13988 preventing and combating
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity and sexual orientation and in
that order he ordered all federal
agencies to look into their policies
that relate to sex and to redefine all
of their policies so that sex is
redefined to include gender identity
which makes sex a meaningless concept in
federal administrative law so over the
course of the first six months or so a
little bit more of 2021 the
administration the
department of health and human services
the department of housing and urban
development the departments of education
and justice have essentially rewritten
their policies to completely redefine
sex to include gender identity um
and they did that
essentially without notifying the
american people they dropped this
initial um
executive order the first day of taking
office and they announced that but
nobody really knows what it means yeah
if you're if you're not like deeply
involved in this you don't know what it
means to redefine sex to include gender
identity most people
don't don't understand the implications
of that the implications of that for
housing and urban development are that
it's impossible to have a female only
domestic violence shelter in the u.s
anymore if a man wants to enter a
federally funded domestic violence
shelter and the shelter wants to exclude
him on the basis that he's male he can
complain that he has a female gender
identity and that the shelter is
discriminating against him
but when i say that the agencies did
this without notifying the american
public that is largely true because they
went unnoticed but what i specifically
mean is that there is a law in place
that says if a federal agency wants to
change its regulations it has to go
through a formal rule-making process and
it's very complicated but
it really boils down to this the agency
has to notify the public and give the
public an opportunity to comment and
that that
period is usually something like 60 or
90 days and then there are specific
rules in place that the agency is
supposed to read all the comments
publish the comments answer the comments
etc before changing its law or before
changing its rule and the administration
didn't do any of that here none of it
do you think people putting these laws
in place like biden or people who are
high up do you think they're being like
fooled into this as well or do you think
they're aware of the ramifications like
i can see someone saying oh no this is
just for the benefit of people to make
everyone feel included but not actually
aware of what it's doing
right i mean i think two things one
thing i think is that president biden
knows exactly what the word woman means
but i also think that
uh he's gotten a lot of money to do this
you know that's another thing that these
industries are doing is fueling
campaigns the the democratic party has
essentially been bought by an industry
whose objective it is to obliterate the
material reality of biological sex the
same is true in the uk with labor right
i mean i don't want to say that the
democrats in labor are identical they're
important differences but um
but both political parties have been
completely bought by an industry that is
hell-bent on obliterating the material
reality of biological sex throughout
society so on the one hand i you know
president biden is not confused about
what a woman is but he's paid to do what
he's doing
okay and do you think the people behind
this you mentioned it kind of drifting
up from post-modernism but do you think
the pharmaceutical industry pushing
drugs is the main culprit behind this
i think it's a combination
i think it's a combination of
post-modernism
and there are other examples in our
society where we're sort of pretending
like reality isn't real right um
we're at a very dangerous time for any
number of reasons but in this instance i
do think that it's a combination of
postmodern denial of the material
reality of biological sex and an
industry that is fueling
that right like they sort of took that
and ran with it and they said oh great
let's um
let's use it for profit and let's put a
generation's worth of kids and young
people on a lifetime's worth of hormones
let's start blocking puberty for all
these kids let's start giving young
people cross-sex hormones they'll be on
them for the rest of their lives that is
not an exaggeration if you start this
path you're on it for the rest of your
life
and
and pharma is like great we're gonna
make a bunch of money
okay so let's let's delve into that a
little bit um
what happens to someone so so say you're
a
11 year old girl
and you have decided that you identify
as a boy and you want to be a man when
you grow up what exactly happens to you
my understanding is that the typical
path is that a girl in that situation
would go on something called puberty
blockers a puberty blocker was designed
for a condition where a kid might enter
puberty at an abnormally young age right
there's a very rare condition where a
kid might enter puberty or start puberty
at it at the age of eight or nine or
something like that and that's hard
right like that's really psychologically
hard for that kid the kids you know
peers aren't there yet and it's just
difficult so uh puberty blockers were
developed to help that kid delay puberty
until it was more developmentally
appropriate but now they're just being
given to kids who are starting puberty
at an appropriate age but who don't want
to go through their correct sex puberty
and
so they'll be on puberty blockers for a
couple of years and then at some point
and it varies by state but at some point
if a kid wants to go on cross-sex
hormones they can do that as well
meaning a young woman can go on
testosterone a young man can go on
estrogen and this this is just
it's horrible i mean it's just
devastating it has devastating impacts
on these people's bodies it is known to
cause bone density loss it is known to
cause cancer uh a large percentage of
people who go on these drugs will die
prematurely when they otherwise would
not it is incredibly incredibly
dangerous and
the most recent one of the recent times
i was on tucker carlson
he asked me um why isn't the medical
establishment stopping yeah the medical
establishment is part of this
these are doctors who are prescribing
these
dangerous and potentially lethal drugs
to children
they must also be brainwashed to a
degree though because i mean most
doctors become doctors because they want
i'm not a fan of doctors i had multiple
health problems and
i was i am not a fan of doctors but i do
know that the doctors that treated me
even though they made mistakes were
trying to help me so i would assume most
of the doctors who were prescribing
these
i would hope
not that it makes any difference because
the end result is still terrible but i
would assume that the doctors who are
prescribing these medications are under
uh uh believe that they're stopping
people from committing suicide or
something otherwise why like why and how
could they do that
well i think a lot of them do fit into
that category exactly but
but it i think you're right that it's
not most doctors but here's what's
happening we've got these things called
gender clinics a gender clinic we had
like two of them uh something like 10
years ago and now we've got something
like 700 in this country and so what i
think
what i think doctors do
uh the ones who think they're doing the
right thing a lot of doctors a kid will
present and say doctor i think i'm
transgender and the doctor feels
unqualified to handle that kind of thing
and so the doctor thinking that she or
he is doing the right thing makes a
referral to the experts or the gender
clinic they think that's appropriate
it's like when i was
18 um i was anorexic and i saw my doctor
and my doctor referred me to a eating
disorder clinic right that's just sort
of how things work um and i'm very happy
to say that that was effective and i
stopped being anorexic so that's good
but that's that's what these doctors are
doing they're referring kids to gender
clinics thinking they're doing the right
thing and the people who run the gender
clinics i do not think are motivated by
good motives at all i think these are
horrible people who are paid to ruin
people's lives
wow okay
okay so once a kid starts these what
what happens if they change their mind
like i've seen people online where
they were kind of influenced by their
peers and they thought it was the cool
thing and that's what they believed at
the time and then they get to be 21 and
and they're like okay
that was wrong i don't want that anymore
what do those people do
so in theory it's possible to
stop
uh after having taken puberty blockers
um the long-term effects of puberty
blockers by themselves are not known so
we don't know for example if it's ever
possible to stop taking puberty blockers
and then have a normal puberty i've
heard people say it is possible and i've
heard people say it's not possible wow
but we part of the reason we don't know
that is that almost no one takes puberty
blockers for a few years and then stops
the vast majority of kids that go on
puberty blockers go on to take opposite
sex hormones the vast vast majority go
on to take opposite sex hormones
and those are
absolutely not reversible there's no
question about that and yeah we're
seeing a lot a lot of young people
mostly in their 20s having gone through
all of this and now they they want to go
back but they're not reversible so
these young people often have to go
through sort of
psychological torture to realize what
they have put themselves through
sometimes with the permission of their
parents
you know always with the permission of
their doctor
and often
being encouraged by their therapists
and um
we have a lot of young women these days
with a lot of artificially lowered
voices because they can't get their
voices back once they've been on
testosterone a lot of women
have had double mastectomies
and will never have their natural
breasts back
and people sort of brush that off and
say well they can just get synthetic
ones and it's like how are we here
how on earth are we here um and it's
there are plenty of boys and young men
who are going through this as well it's
just much more prevalent in young women
because it's young women who are being
pressured into this more than boys and
that's not to say i lack sympathy for
the boys who are going through this of
course i have tremendous sympathy for
boys
you know how how graphic do you can can
we be here no be graphic people should
know what's going on like this is awful
i mean there are young men who have had
their testicles and penises removed
and um
you know to go through regret for having
done something like that i i don't know
i'm not a guy but it just
i just so feel for these young people
who were pushed into something as
dangerous as
and and these kids are being sterilized
i mean we can't forget that we're having
young people make the decision to be to
sterilize themselves um
kids who can't buy alcohol are making
the decision to sterilize themselves and
i think it's outrageous so i really feel
for these young people who are
realizing what happened to them
and they're trying to get their lives
back
that is crazy it's insane that you can
convince a society to think in a certain
way to this degree it's terrifying
it is i mean there are a lot of people
who are starting to explore
uh
you know patterns of cult-like behavior
we're starting to
look at whether
people who engage in this are engaged in
cult-like behavior i've heard the phrase
mass psychosis um that that this is a
societal mass psychosis that's going on
we're all sort of gripped by this
yeah well that's what it looks like
can you describe um the the bo stock
case
so um
what eventually became the bose stockade
i say bostock i don't know which is
right i don't know if it's boss talking
you're probably wrong you're either
right here i honestly don't know but um
so so
bostock i forget his first name he was a
gay man who was fired for being gay i
think that that was not contested that
was agreed and there was another man
named zarta and he was fired for being
gay uncontested so these two guys who
were fired for being gay sued their
employers and said you can't fire me for
being gay
and their cases made their way through
the courts
there was another case called stevens
and stevens is a man was a man who
demanded to be
referred to as a woman for employment
purposes and his employer said well
we're not going to do that and so amy
stevens sued his employer
and stephen's case made its way through
the court system so
all three cases eventually reached the
supreme court and the supreme court
decided to take them and then what it
did is it
smushed them all together basically the
legal term
shouldn't say smush the the court joined
the cases um which meant that the cases
were going to be heard together and
decided on together and so it ended up
being called bostock but it's actually
three cases two gay men and one man who
identifies as a woman
and the court eventually ruled that
under title vii which is our employment
discrimination law anti-discrimination
law
employers cannot
discriminate against people on the basis
of either sexual orientation or
transgender status
and it puts that phrase in quotes
and it never defines what transgender
status is it just assumes that
transgender status is a thing
without telling us what it means this
episode was sponsored by bio optimizers
the folks at bio optimizers have done it
again they've just released their new
formula for magnesium breakthrough the
most potent magnesium supplement on the
market
if you struggle with anxiety have
trouble sleeping depression or just
overworked and stressed
try magnesium even before you try
meditation and honestly go low carb if
you're suffering might as well get rid
of the food you love too right i'm
kidding it works though it's worth it
but something to add on to that or do
anyway magnesium supplementation about
50 of americans are magnesium deficient
which means you really might be which is
crazy because it helps with all sorts of
things from diabetes muscle relaxation
and blood pressure to metabolism and
digestion there's a reason it's called
our body's master mineral
the problem is most supplements are
synthetic or only have a couple of types
of magnesium magnesium breakthrough by
bio-optimizers has all seven organic
forms plus cofactors to increase
absorption ensuring stress relief and
high cognitive performance
many of their customers immediately
notice the effects
be in charge of your well-being take one
before bed every night and see how you
feel in the morning bio optimizers even
has an exclusive offer to get you
started
visit
magbreakthrough.com
peterson or use code peterson at
checkout for 10 off it's also a great
gift
magbreakthrough.com
peterson uh next question what what is
table 42 of the fbi's uniform crime
reporting program
so that is the fbi's way of
recording and reporting crime statistics
by sex the last data that i have seen
reports
the last i've seen is 2020 and it
reports um
crime statistics by sex and it shows
unsurprisingly which it has shown for
the past several decades since it's been
doing the program i think it started in
the 1930s that men overwhelmingly commit
most violent and sex crimes it's usually
something like men commit about 87
percent of murders and
somewhere around there for aggravated
assaults men commit something like 95 to
98 of rapes and we can only know that
because the fbi records it that way
based on data that it gets from local
law enforcement agencies
and i'm following we should see let's
see we're in may of 2022 we should see
2021 data pretty soon and i'm following
it because i want to see how is the fbi
going to report crime statistics we've
already in other words we cannot talk
about male violence against women if we
cannot talk about who are the male
people and who are the female people
under biden's executive order
presumably the fbi
should have to
obliterate that reporting system because
now gender identity is all that matters
but it hasn't done so yet to the best of
my knowledge
and um you know we'll see what it does
for 2021 i know what i wanted to say
there was a group of
attorney generals state attorney
generals that submitted a letter to
christopher wray the head of the fbi
and and said we want you to start
recording a category called non-binary
we want you to record male crime female
crime and non-binary crime and i don't
think the fbi has done it yet but
they've been asked to
okay well give it another five or ten
years two years maybe
given the direction we're heading in
okay let's see what else do i have here
that we should definitely talk about
um
let's do
okay this is probably good just for
everybody to know what what is the
equality act
the equality act was first introduced in
2015 and it was reintroduced last year
and what it would do is redefine the
word sex to include the words gender
identity among others
for purposes of
all united states civil rights law
so this would mean that for purposes of
united states civil rights law the
category of women and girls would cease
to have any meaning
including public accommodations law so
this is one of what i think is one of
the most outrageous aspects of this
whole thing
we have in our civil rights law a public
accommodations law and it's from 1964
and it says public accommodations which
means businesses right it means like
bars restaurants movies the whole thing
you're not allowed to discriminate on
the basis of race great right crowning
victory of the us civil rights movement
after
decades of
legal racial segregation which was
horrible
the civil rights movement fought back
and said you know black people have just
as much right to use the bathroom in
this restaurant or in this hotel as
white people there came to be a case
called heart of atlanta motel which was
explicitly white only i mean that was
their policy they had a white only
policy and a black family sued and said
you can't do that and the supreme court
eventually said you're right they can't
do that so no more racial segregation in
places of public accommodation good
major victory for civil rights now
what the equality act would do is
redefine all the words um so so the
civil rights act prohibits
discrimination on the basis of several
categories and what this would do is add
sex including gender identity to
our public accommodations law which
would mean that every hotel every
restaurant every stadium every arena
every place of public accommodation
would be prohibited from discriminating
against men in the bathroom if the men
had a female gender identity
all over the country
this is so wild
this is so it's so wild it's so 1982
okay
next question i still have a whole bunch
of these to go to get to get through uh
who's dana rivers
dana rivers let me just go back for one
second and say the equality act passed
in the house of representatives in i
think february of 2021 and it passed in
the senate judiciary committee in march
of 2021 however starting in march of
2021 the majority leader of the senate
charles schumer has had the authority to
bring it to a vote in the united states
senate and he has not done so that's
over a year he has had the ability to
pass this thing and he hasn't done it
and i think it's because he doesn't have
the votes for it because i think that
notwithstanding what people say in
public i think our politicians are
starting to listen to us which i think
is a good thing
i i hope i hope you're right um before
we get into
dana rivers
um
let me think if this kind of thing
passes so say you're talking to someone
and they just say no this is it's too
it's too graphic what you're saying just
isn't true if this kind of uh if these
kind of laws
come into play what kind of changes
could we potentially see on a societal
level
well i mean so
my city dc has a very similar law
already on the books and um i've walked
into a bathroom in a a women's room in
a restaurant and there was a guy in
there and he was wearing a long dress
and pink nail polish and long blonde
hair and a lot of makeup and it was
terrifying so we're just going to see a
lot more of that
yeah that is terrifying i don't know
like p i don't think people talk about
that either is it's scary if you see
like you
you're not allowed to talk about that
for some reason but if you see a man
dressed up as a woman and it's like
looks like a man
and they're like close to you it's scary
it's objectively scary because it's also
like i don't know how stable this person
is they're a lot bigger than me um i'm
not allowed to say anything about it or
act like something's off uh it's scary
right and i think that is a reasonable
reaction to that kind of thing
yeah but i do i want people to to stop
thinking they're not allowed to say
anything i understand why people do
think we're not allowed to say anything
there's a tremendous amount of social
pressure to go along with this and to
not be mean and to be nice to the man
and the pink dress i know i get it but
you know i
i really think that even though it is
republicans in the political arena who
are standing up against this
americans across the political spectrum
could kill this if we would get together
and start talking about it i really
think we could
yeah i agree i agree well that's the
purpose of this podcast i think i'm
going to do a few more on this topic
because um
you know
five maybe five or six years ago i
thought
you know i think my dad mostly started
talking about this and i was like he
sounds kind of paranoid it sounds like
he's a little bit paranoid about this
topic and and then now you see what's
happening now with like i keep using the
example of women's swim team but that
would that just made me so angry i was
like how could you do that to the people
on the swim team and how can everyone
stand there and think and and pretend
it's okay
well that point that points to something
else that i just want to highlight which
is there's no amount of capitulating
that will please these people
and by these people i mean the industry
that is fighting to abolish sex and
here's why i'm saying that now
you know i think that i i think i
i think that what your dad said was
basically i will use people's preferred
pronouns i just don't want to be
compelled to use them
yeah i mean that's a completely
reasonable thing to to to say i mean i
won't use people's preferred pronouns
but if your dad wants to use them okay
you know but um he just said he didn't
want to be forced to or compelled to
yeah not not good enough
not good enough for today's gender
identity movement
yeah
yep
pretty crazy okay um what do you think
the impact of the trump presidency was
on women's rights
well i mean
now we're shifting gears a little bit
but obviously one of the biggest impacts
of
that presidency whose name i don't say
um
was the supreme court and you know the
three justices that are now poised to
overturn roe v wade
and you know i will say the prior
administration was obviously not as
horrific on the topic of gender identity
as the current administration but it
wasn't great either i mean it did a
couple things that i was glad to see it
do but it could have done a lot more and
i wish it had
okay
so how do you think we avoid like what
do we do going forward how do we try and
change the direction that things are
heading in we just start talking about
it we absolutely have to start talking
about it so again thank you so much for
having me on i know that people feel
under a tremendous amount of social
pressure to go along with it and to not
fight back but that has consequences and
so you know i don't want anyone to lose
their employment but if your employer
tells you that you have to start putting
your preferred pronouns in your email
signature please resist if you can and i
should say it's maybe not obvious to
everyone why preferred pronouns are
related to all of this but if you delve
into this topic in any depth it's very
clear that the whole concept of
preferred pronouns is not just some kind
of courtesy it's not just some kind of
new fad that we're doing it's a very
deliberate strategy to make people
forget that we can very obviously see
what sex each other is like i can
clearly see that you are a woman i do
not need you to have she her in your
zoom screen right i mean yeah but the
preferred pronouns are much more
pernicious than they seem to be um so
please resist if you can and and talk to
each other you know talk to
talk to people especially parents like
yourself right like parents across the
political spectrum do not want their
children to be told that anyone can be a
boy or a girl on their say-so um i think
parents have a huge amount of power here
to help push back
yeah
yeah okay i think that's that's good
advice just say what you believe and i i
think people could also say what they
believe under the assumption that other
people
also believe that because you get into a
situation sometimes where there's one
person in the room who's loud and
everyone else is thinking the same thing
and not saying anything
so this is a classic case of emperor's
new clothes right in the fable the
emperor's new clothes nobody would
acknowledge that the emperor was naked
and the reason that they wouldn't
acknowledge that the emperor was naked
was because nobody else was
acknowledging that the emperor was naked
so they didn't want to be stupid or they
didn't want to seem stupid and then one
time you know once the little kid said
the emperor's not wearing any clothes
everybody felt free to say it that's
exactly what's going on here
wild
but i also do want to say in terms of
what can we do um
elected officials at all levels of
government are are dealing with this
local state and federal and every single
american has
an ability if not a responsibility to
contact your local officials and tell
them what you think i don't care about
political party i don't care if you're a
republican and you're represented by a
democrat or vice versa or the same you
know a lot of people think it's useless
to fight the democrats on this and i
understand why
um they're they're showing us what they
think but um it's not useless because if
you tell them what you think then they
can never say that they didn't know
even if they don't change course they
can never say that they didn't know and
so we can all push back on this with our
elected officials and there are things
that republicans have to hear too as i
said republicans are the only political
party pushing back on this at all and
i'm glad that they are
but i don't know if a lot of republicans
really understand the urgency i was
meeting with um
staffer for a republican senator and he
sort of listened
politely and then said well you know i
hope you know that my boss agrees with
you and i was like well that's nice but
is your boss gonna do anything like how
many kids have to be mutilated before
your boss takes action and that was on
the republican side so
republicans have to hear from us too
yeah that's a good point it's so strong
in the other direction right now that
it's just a sticky territory to wade
into so i suppose as a politician you
wouldn't want to take a firm stand
against it otherwise you'd be the
politician taking a firm stand against
it and then you'd be the transphobic
politician and then who knows if you're
gonna get elected right
that's how strong it's going in one
direction
yeah i mean to be fair there are
republicans in congress who have
introduced some good bills tom cotton
has a really good bill in the senate
and there's another um sorry mike lee
has a really good bill in the senate to
protect women's sports i believe the
cotton bill would make sure that state
prisons are segregated by sex and that's
a good thing so there are things that
are happening which is great and
republicans are taking a stand some
but i also just want everyone to know
that there was a bill passed in the
state of south carolina recently to
protect women's sports at all levels
from elementary school through college
in south carolina and by my count 14
state senate democrats
no sorry 14 house democrats and six
senate democrats voted for this bill
so things are changing there are
democrats at least at the state level
who are willing to take a stand and
that's a good thing
okay before we wrap it up can you tell
me a bit about dana rivers
so dana rivers was born david warfield
and
he lives in california
and in november of 2016
i should say for several
years he was very active in an effort to
shut down mitch fest which was a
woman-only music festival
mostly lesbians but women-only music
festival in michigan and he worked very
hard to get that shut down and in
november 2016 there was a lesbian couple
in oakland who had a teenage son
and they had been very active in mitch
fest for several years
and the police received a call of a
shooting and they arrived at the home of
this lesbian couple and their teenage
son and dana rivers who by that point
was claiming to be a woman
uh was standing in the lawn uh covered
in blood and i believe holding a gun and
several knives and the teenage boy was
lying on the ground in front of him and
the two women inside had been brutally
murdered
and he has been charged with several
counts of aggravated murder and uh that
case has been pending since 2016.
so he has not been convicted he is being
housed in the santa rita jail in
california and classified as female
oof
yeah and the trial has been scheduled
numerous times
and rescheduled his plea is insanity
and
the last i checked the court had sort of
continued the case several times waiting
for the doctor's report
to assess the insanity plea but this has
been going on for years and i honestly i
am not entirely sure what is going on
with the case and i can't find out
currently the trial is scheduled for
this july but that could change
brutal okay okay cara um if people want
to follow you online or want to keep up
with this and what you're doing where
should they go
so you can go to www.cared
or www.womensdeclarationusa.com
you can follow me on twitter at kdansky
i'm also on facebook using my name
karadanski and please buy my book it's
on amazon abolition of sex how the
transgender agenda harms women and girls
thank you so much you're so welcome
we're gonna link everything in show
notes if anyone's interested in the book
but
the book is available the book is
available on audible just as of the
other day oh good congratulations thank
you well hopefully this podcast
encourages people to start talking about
this and that other people are thinking
what they're thinking that this is crazy
so thank you very much for coming on and
what you're doing
perfect thanks for having me